[Musique]
la satisfaction
voyager ensemble
le lien est
à votre service
le dialogue
le transporter
nous faire confiance
[Musique]
tu dois être au dépôt tout les jours à
4h du matin et me récupérer la fin
du planning journalier et après
l'arrivée de chauffage et l'accueil je
lui indique son bus ont fait ensemble
contrôle du véhicule on contrôlera et la
carrosserie aussi des nouveaux moteurs
quand il ya une anomalie nouvelle jeux
conçus sur l'affiché date pas d'hier
mais ont par la suite a aussi réussi ce
pari sont des 2,6
[Musique]
ya 12 et 12 affaire nous
bon ben on veux tu oui c'est important
car pour les gens qui travaillent
surtout le matin
[Musique]
maintenant les bus vont sillonner l'île
ils vont récupérer le voyageur et c'est
parti pour une bonne journée
moi je vais me reposer quelques minutes
[Musique]
mais en gare de saint benoît tous les
jours il ya des personnes qui viennent
prennent le bus pour aller au travail au
boulot ou pour plusieurs
activité on voit là moi c'est en garde
accompagnée
orienter les personnes
les informations sont là mais pas tout
le monde arrive à déchiffrer les
informations donc je suis là pour les
aider et qu'ils puissent prendre les
aurea et le bus à prendre messieurs
dames bonjour
pardon un petit passage s'il vous plaît
merci
[Musique]
évidemment il ya beaucoup beaucoup de
personnes clients
pour le matin la route
c'est le moment de la journée où
avec le client j'ai envie d'apporter 1
il ya meilleur leur donner envie de
prendre le bus qui se sentent rassurés
accompagner
ces dames en jouant toujours avec la
ceinture obligatoire dans les buts pour
conduire niasse ou rien en fait je fais
l'embarcation je renseigne les voyageurs
se renseignent d'information en
embarquer qu ils sont les personnes sont
installées je demande de le mettre
mathieu leur sainte trinité passer en
cas d'accident exacte et ils sont pas
couverts en fait trouvé par un jeune et
pour leur confort essayages
mieux que les anciens airbus il ya un
convoi ya la bouffe et lé président us b
dans les mousses qui peut
avoir accès et les crimes des bus les
bus climatisés un lien qui se crée avec
certaines personnes qui soient des
personnages et moins jeunes en fonte ou
voilà les personnes qui prennent souvent
les bus pour aller au travail formation
ou loisirs unis connaissent c'est bien
pour certaines connaissent ils
connaissent ma façon de travailler bonne
journée mais ces dames on voyage vous
mon week-end avant
[Musique]
non
le championnat à l'image de mon
rôle en tant qu'accompagnateur de ces
baignades et jaser si l'on noté depuis
la musique trop forte ou bien jean plus
dans les bus
ce moment là nous en tant
qu'accompagnateur on est formés pour
intervenir ce de ce genre d'intervention
et on a des postures les positions et
des langages adapté pour intervenir sur
ces gens d'ici ce que j'ai envie de dire
aux clients en fait c'est qu'ils se
sentent rassurés quand ils nous voient
et que on est là pour lui au confort et
de sécurité
[Musique]
en tant que conducteur l'accueil des
clients déjà c'est primordial et
accueillaient les clients avec le
sourire c'est encore mieux et on fait
amener aussi à informer les clients sur
des six nations quant à eux trois ces
produits on doit avoir les sur ce qui se
passe dans le bus est ce qui se passe à
l'extérieur du xixe pendant que les gens
attendent leur tour
[Musique]
c'est un métier que je voulais faire
depuis tout péter
parce que déjà mon père il était dedans
et à chaque fois qu'ils veulent et le
voir avec le bus je voyais ça comme
quelque chose de bon j'ai envie d'y
aller en tant que conducteur que je suis
un usager du bisse aussi et vivre
ensemble voyager ensemble ça sera ça se
passera dans le dans les meilleures
conditions
c'est mon métier consiste aussi
intervenir dans différentes situations
telles que sur des cas de secouristes on
est formé à la formation de la cité mais
on est aussi amené à
anticiper sur d'éventuelles malaise
l'anticipation est justement importante
c'est ce qui nous permet de prévenir
avant que les personnes fassent un
éventuel malaise on puisse se blesser en
tombant
c'est ce qui pourrait être rassurant sur
le réseau de sa voix que le client il
peut voyager quoi qu'il arrive nous on
est amené à intervenir avec la formation
nécessaires justement et
on s'est passé le relais comme il faut
c'est-à-dire appelé les pompiers ou le
samu les autorités compétentes selon la
situation ce qui me plaît c'est le
contact avec le client de les voir
satisfait de voir que notre présence les
rassure beaucoup on se sent quand même
très important on voit la différence
quand on est dans les transports avec
les clients et quand il quand il n'ya
pas d'accompagnateur c'est ce qui fait
que quand on rentre chez nous on a la
satisfaction d'avoir passé une bonne
journée d'avoir été important est
d'avoir marqué les esprits
[Musique]
parfois qu'avec le must reste dépôt pour
des entretiens et les entretiens
périodiques ou soit des remplacements
de plaquettes rapport au véhicule est
heureux que les gens racontent ça c'est
juste pour des contrôles précis des
contrôles de sécurité mon métier
consiste à offrir tout s'agit
d'entretien et les réparer réparations
mécaniques
les contrôleurs
les contrôles de sécurité comme des
contrôles de feu contre le pare-brise
balais d'essuie-glace des roues la quête
est très sympa à travailler sur sur les
nouveaux des nouveaux cars jaunes à une
fête déjà de travailler sur un véhicule
neuf
ça apporte une très grande satisfaction
de savoir aussi que tous les jours et
que quand on est entre le chef et qui
peut rouler que tout le monde peut se
déplacer grâce à nous aussi d'être au
service du client même si clients et
c'est tout
[Musique]